Apple is one of the biggest companies in
the world but over the last couple of
years it seems they have been on a
downturn and a peaked out so here's the
top seven reasons why Apple has been
failing recently and we're starting
right now with number one lack of
innovation since that iPhone six came
out there really hasn't been very many
big upgrades with the iPhone 6s and 6s
plus we got 3d touch but most people
Ginni we care about that and on the
newest version the iPhone XR they
actually removed it and I don't even
think that many people noticed with the
iPhone 7
not only is removing the headphone jack
but also the physical home button which
does not go well with most people with
the iPhone 8 the only difference I was
really noticeable was that the back was
made of glass now of course there was
the traditional camera and crossing
upgrades but as friend icing new
features there really wasn't any for
example Siri with the iPhone 4s when the
virtual assistants were pretty new and
unheard of and touch ID with the iPhone
5s that completely revolutionized how
you'd unlock your phone and pay for
things and with the iPhone 6 this is the
first time that Apple really enlarges
greensight of course Apple did enter his
face ID but for most people face it he
was actually just a downgrade from touch
ID and it was slower and less safe and
secure as it is evident Apple a really
cool enticing features pretty much every
generation or at least every other
generation up until the iPhone 6 but
since the iPhone 6 it seems like a plus
stagnated and lacked innovation and
since there's a lack of innovation and
nothing new really coming out most
people are happy with the phones they
currently have there's simply no reason
to go from the iPhone 6 to I phone 7 or
8 or even X are in a lot of these cases
people actually lose out on features by
upgrading like the headphone jack and
touch ID plus the phones that most
people have are more than capable of
handling their day-to-day tasks for
example with the original iPhone when
the iPhone 3G and 4 came on became very
slow it couldn't handle all the new
tasks like the new apps like YouTube and
things like that but nowadays the iPhone
6 is pretty much just as capable as the
new
f1x are sure if you put it side-by-side
you may be able to find a noticeable
difference but for most people this is
pretty negligible and it doesn't matter
for them people are simply satisfied
with what they already have but if there
is no real speed upgrade or feature
difference as a result even if people
have a good amount of cash to spend on
something like a phone it simply don't
choose to because buying a new phone
it's not on top of their priorities
they'd much rather spend the money into
something that needs upgrading like
their old laptop or their TV since
people use your phone so often they're
able to sense a generational gap much
easier on their phones and other devices
as a result even if their other device
are lagging behind more than their
phones they're more likely to upgrade
their phones but recently since there's
a lack of big generational gaps people
are satisfied with the phones they had
and much rather spend their money
somewhere else it's similar to what
happened with computers in the late
1990s and early 2000s every year it
seemed like you were left behind and
does even if you just bought a computer
just a couple of months ago and it was
as fast progression that made people
want to upgrade very frequently however
nowadays you can buy a nice computer and
unit for several years and you wouldn't
feel like you're being left behind and
recently the iPhone has reached a point
where you can buy a phone and keep it
for several years and you wouldn't
really notice a difference and this key
factor has led to a lot less iPhone
upgrades and lot less revenue for Apple
and who could forget about a post ever
increasing starting prices what started
with the $500 with the original iPhone
when I've got $550 with the iPhone 4 and
then with the iPhone 4 has $650 and it
stay with this solid $650 entry mark
until the iPhone 8 when it suddenly went
up to 700 and with the iPhone XR it went
up one more time to $750 over the last
10 years
sorry pressure the iPhone has gone up by
$250 which is a 50% increase which is
absolutely outrageous and to make things
even worse the iPhone X heart doesn't
really look like a premium product
it looks like the iPhone 10s and tonight
max are the real premium products and it
looks like the iPhone XR is like the
iPhone 5c with all of its playful colors
furthermore it seems like the iPhone XR
was tricked out of a lot of qualities at
the iPhone 8 an A+ hat for the same
price for example why does the iPhone XR
not have a dog camera like the iPhone 8
plus and why does it not even have a 3d
touch which is offer since the iPhone 6s
it's not that 3d touch display that
effective and people use it that much
but it's the principle of Apple removing
it from a more expensive phone it seems
that the iPhone 10s and 10x Macs are the
real successors to the iPhone 8 and 8
plus and that iPhone XR is just like a
successor to like the iPhone 5c and this
means that Apple is expecting that
average customer to spend over a
thousand dollars on a phone that is
literally double what they're charging
at the very beginning usually people are
okay with spending a bit more money for
Apple products because they see that
better quality and more features
available with Apple products but
recently Apple has gone to a range of
diminishing returns where the extra my
spent really just isn't worth it at all
not only that but the newer iPhone XR
doesn't even seem like a upgrade over
the iPhone 8 or 8 plus sure has the
bigger screen but other than that it
really doesn't stick out in any one way
and it is definitely not worth a price
jump Apple always had trouble entering
the Chinese and Indian market because of
how expensive their phones were but now
it seem like they're going to struggle
in the North America and European market
as well so unless Apple does something
about these ever-increasing prices they
may just keep seeing a downturn in sales
not only is Apple charging more for
their devices but they're also removing
essentials that people love through the
biggest removals or
touch ID the headphone jack and a
physical home button fingerprints have
been a standard of security for several
decades and the most secure places like
banks in the white house as a result it
is as in green trust people haven't
now they simply don't have in face ID as
a result the removal of touched idea was
definitely a mistake on Apple's part and
even though they will not bring it back
the removal of it will always hurt their
sales numbers after the physical home
button you just can't replicate a nice
tactile click with the vibrations the
new iPhone 10 gestures are great and do
the job just fine but I'm not sure about
you guys but I definitely missed the old
home button from the iPhone 6 there's
just something that doesn't feel right
about the home button on the iPhone 7
and 8 and finally the removal of the
headphone jack
it seems very clear that the Apple
removed the headphone jack just to force
people to buy their in air pots a lot of
people don't want to buy air pots or use
them even if they can afford it because
it is so easy to lose and misplace
forget about ear plugs what about all
the devices that use a 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack
now of course according to them you
should use the Lightning the 3.5
millimeter encaptured but why I even
include that way you just include the
actual headphone jack on the phone also
they don't even include the converter
anymore with their newer phones so you
actually have to buy it from Apple's
website and of course there's the
argument about how you can charge your
phone and listen to music at the same
time clearly there is a lot of issues
that come from removing a headphone jack
and it definitely wasn't a smart choice
with Apple in the end I post ripping out
all of these essential things in the
iPhone have transformed it into a
completely different product that isn't
as desirable anymore
there are several stories about Apple
notoriously charging a very high price
for easy repairs like screen repairs on
top of this if you're trying to repair
your MacBook Apple oftentimes charges
more to prepare the MacBook then it
would cost you to buy a new MacBook all
together furthermore it seems like
apples intentionally leaving behind
older users recently the story about
Apple slowing down older phones made
headlines Apple claimed they slid on
older phones in an effort to improve
battery life but to a lot of people this
seems like a clear case of planned
obsolescence
and people definitely would not have
gotten angry Apple if they clearly give
the users the choice of choosing between
battery life and performance it is in
fact that Apple forced his aunt users
that makes them seem deceptive and
greedy Indiana it is as lack of
transparency and sky-high repair charges
that left a lot of Apple fans to lose
trust an Apple and this has deterred log
people from upgrading their phones with
Apple or buying other Apple products
Steve Jobs always helped Apple get
through a heart sometimes for example in
the early 2000s when Apple's on the
brink of bankruptcy Steve Jobs in Trista
iPod and save Apple and then in 2007 he
introduced an iPhone which is pretty
much the key to Apple success today but
without Steve Jobs outputs esteem is
kind of lost actually of course they
have the improvements every single year
in technologically but there simply
isn't something newer and innovative and
fun there were just something different
about how Steve Jobs made new product
and introduced them it's just a fire in
his eyes and a confidence in his voice
like he doesn't cure cancer or something
something has changed about apples and
Steve Jobs left or should I say a lack
of change has existed in Apple we'll
just let them to stagnate after Steve
Jobs died there seems to only have been
two big upgrades which is touch ID'd and
a bigger screen which is probably
discussed and fine last when he was
actually alive clearly the lack of Steve
Jobs has definitely had a negative
impact on Apple as a whole as for number
seven the excitement for smartphones has
simply died down in North America the
iPhone 6 was when the iPhone
transitioned from a luxury premium
product to an everyday commodity until
the iPhone 6 everyone was very excited
as to what app would bring out and
wanted to get the newest phone as quick
as possible but after the iPhone 6 came
off pretty much everybody even your
fifth grade cousin had the new iPhone
and it wasn't that cool to have a new i4
anymore when the iPhone 6 released
people waited outside Apple stores for
several days to be the first person get
it a person one of the iPhone six
product could avoid the wait and got an
iPhone 6 that weekend at Sam's
but it was the culture of waiting and
excitement that surrounded the front
that entices people to wait that long
but soon after the iPhone 6 released and
everyone had it that excitement slowly
died down people would rather just order
online and have it show up on their
doorstep a couple of days later of
course there are still the die-hard
Apple fans who wait outside Apple stores
every single year for the new iPhone but
I'm talking about the average person a
couple of years ago a common
conversation would have looked like this
hey you sure about the new iPhone
yeah it looks so cool I can't wait to
get one but now it looks like this did
you hear about the new iPhone that came
out last week know what's really the
same thing right yeah pretty much yeah
whatever overall the excitement
surrounding getting a new iPhone simply
isn't there anymore and people are happy
with what they have and that is a key
reason why Apple has pretty much
stagnated since the iPhone 6 but it
wasn't always like this
Apple quickly grew to fame and made
billions of dollars if you're interested
in how Apple is able to grow so quickly
it makes you check out my video on its
top 7 reasons why Apple is successful
also if you guys like severe damage drop
a like and consider subscribing you play
to see more videos just like this one
but until then I'm Ari I'll see you guys
on next
[Music]